le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
monter son entreprise c'est l'une des
solutions pour se sortir d'une situation
de chômage pour encourager les jeunes à
créer leur emploi
le département a lancé en mai 2016 le
taz le tremplin pour l'activité des
jeunes
ce dispositif propose une aide
financière et un accompagnement aux
entrepreneurs de moins de 30 ans
jonathan veut créer un salon de thé
ambulants sa demande de subvention vient
tout juste d'être accepté
[Musique]
alors on est dans mon futur local de
pâtissier de production pâtisserie ici
ça va être l'espace cuisson ou je vais
faire mais craignent les bases ici ça va
être mon espace où je vais mettre les
frigos qu'on veuille pour pouvoir
stocker alors ça c'est ma future tenue
de travail tout est presque prêt et
jonathan s'y voit déjà
ce jeune pâtissier de 27 ans est en
train de monter son entreprise
et c'est ici qu'il réalisera ses
recettes alors après avoir produit mes
pâtisseries donc du coup ils seront
stockés en fait trop froid dit dans ma
table réfrigérée et puis transporté dans
mes vitrines pour la vente en camion
car jonathan a imaginé un concept
innovant pouvoir faire produire la même
chose qu'un salon monte donc service de
boissons chaudes avec pâtisseries fines
mais en ambulants passion s'est appelée
à lui remet à 2,5 l'outil sur deux ans
j'ai validé main
mention complémentaire en pâtisserie par
la suite après ses trois années de
formation
j'ai travaillé trois ans encore donc en
tant qu'ouvrier j'ai en tant qu'apprenti
fort de cette expérience
jonathan décide de devenir son propre
patron mais pour finaliser l'aménagement
de son atelier et l'achat dé son
matériel
le jeune homme a besoin d'argent il a
fait appel otage au tremplin pour
l'activité des jeunes depuis mars
dix sept noms que j'ai déposé mon
mon dossier donc j'ai en moyenne trois
mois d'attentes donc là ça fait un peu
plus d'une semaine que j'ai reçu la
réponse
une réponse positive c'est une aubaine
pour moi finalisé concrétiser en tout
cas ce cette démarche de pouvoir
m'installer dans les normes
le taz est un dispositif départemental
lancé il ya un an pour accompagner les
jeunes dans la création d'entreprise on
est très heureux et satisfait du premier
bilan sur le tage qui est le tremplin à
l'activité des jeunes puisque nous avons
eu plus de 500 demandes de jeunes de
moins de 30 ans qui ont voulu créer leur
entreprise et bénéficier de l'aide
financière du département de la réunion
jusqu'à 8000 euros c'est vraiment un
coup de pouce pour que ceux qui ont des
projets mais qui n'ont pas les moyens
financiers
ceux qui veulent s'en sortir puisse être
aidé et accompagné avec l'ensemble du
réseau point chances sont que 12 et les
conditions nécessaires les conditions
favorables pour créer leur entreprise
car il ne s'agit pas que d'une aide
financière ce matin jonathan se rend
dans l'un des organismes partenaires du
dispositif
initiative réunion entreprendre fait
partie du réseau point chances que les
jeunes entrepreneurs peuvent activer une
fois éligibles otages on va regarder un
petit peu ensemble des éléments qui sont
dans votre dossier avec le tremplin pour
l'activité des jeunes jonathan père soit
une subvention de 8000 euros
les il a besoin d'une plus grosse somme
pour lancer son activité venu là pour
pouvoir compléter ce qu'on appelle mon
plan de financement sinon c'est le
projet entièrement c'est compliqué de
sortir le financement de sa poche
la finalité c'est de pouvoir convaincre
un organisme bancaire qu'ils puissent
suivre justement ce plan de financement
qui l'étudié
partons travaux chambre des métiers
entre wattignies sciatique
le rôle de l'organisme compléter l'aide
du département et solidifier le dossier
pour rassurer les banques
la particularité c'est de pouvoir prêter
à des jeunes à deux taux défiant toute
concurrence puisque c'est sans intérêt
et sans caution et ce prix m'a fait un
levier auprès des banques c'est à dire
ça va permettre de rassurer un petit peu
le banquier qui pourra lui aussi
intervenir
tu as des dossiers ainsi couple fera
essayer le jeu dire on regarde un petit
peu votre plan de financement c'est ce
sur quoi on va travailler principalement
notre mission de l'organisme accompagner
ces chefs d'entreprise en devenir pro de
pas mal de créateurs d'entreprise c'est
que c'est la première création une
maîtrise de la technicité mais ils n'ont
pas obligatoirement une culture
entrepreneuriale
donc on est là un petit peu pour parer à
ces questionnements et le préparer un
petit peu atteint future création
d'entreprise à les avoir jonathan devra
encore passer devant une commission
avant d'obtenir son prêt et à ta femme
ça fait longtemps que j'attends enfin ça
fait enfin dans une lila je prépare ça
donc je vais plutôt à de finir tout ça
et pouvoir commencer montreux
comme on dit pâtisser le jeune homme
espère pouvoir sillonner les routes dans
son salon de thé ambulants d'ici la fin
de l'année
[Musique]
à la réunion 44% des jeunes étaient sans
emploi en 2016
depuis sa création il ya un an 500
personnes ont fait appel au tremplin
pour l'activité des jeunes
le taz est un dispositif dead
s'adressant aux jeunes âgés de 20 à 30
ans ayant pour projet de monter leur
entreprise
il propose une aide de 8000 euros ainsi
qu'un accompagnement par les organismes
du réseau point chance pour plus de
renseignements vous pouvez consulter le
site du département au www.cn.ca 4 point
fr
[Musique]